so should you use a vector graphic or a
raster graphic well in this case the
star is pretty simple and a pretty
regular shape so I think it's safe to
say a vector graphic is the way to go
especially if you want to scale it with
your app and then should you inline it
or set its source to an external file
for this question I'm actually accepting
both answers because you could argue
either way for inline it's safe to say a
star is a pretty simple shape you could
pretty easily create it with an SVG file
and just simply inline that without
adding too many bytes if you're reusing
an image it does make sense to make it
external which means that you'll be able
to cache it and then not reload it every
time a user visits a new page so in this
case it really depends and if this were
a real app you would just test it to
find out which method is faster